i want to i'm interested about this  because we're both nerds  who who were kids who loved nerd stuff  yeah and i've had this conversation with  seth too we're nerds who love nerd stuff  and now we're adults  and each of us was part of something  that's a big deal to our nerd culture  right like each of us like has managed  to do something that is going to matter  to future generations of nerds right  right yeah is is it so like for me  that's super cool super cool real real  weird and like impossible to wrap my  head around i never thought no one would  ever think that little  rosenbaum little me would ever amount to  anything period the end  that's just the reality